c'est le joyau des parcs nationaux du
pays un incontournable place au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
avec ses 4 millions de visiteurs annuels
ben faty re à lui seul le quart de
toutes les visites dans l'ensemble des
parcs nationaux canadiens
mais cette popularité a un prix mais de
plus en plus bleu quelques années on
voyait jamais du monde sur la pointe là
bas puis d'augmenter plus loin c'est
juste est en train de s'agrandir
s'agrandir la pression des touristes sur
les divers écosystèmes n'a jamais été
aussi forte observe marie-eve marchand
spécialiste de la conservation et
résidents de banff concrètement ça à
quoi comme impact cette pression-là
touristique sur les écosystèmes saleh
plusieurs points différence ça peut être
une pression au quotidien les journées
sont plus en plus longues plus en plus
de monde pour le matin et tard le soir
se dit que la fonte de moins en moins
des espaces pour se nourrir circulez
avec leur petit jeu ce fait les ya plus
de piétons donc être plus en plus de 100
tic sont comme créer comme on peut voir
ici est vraiment qu'au mieux une route
principale mais tout d'un coup y deux
trois quatre hot 100 c'est donc une
multiplication de l'empreinte vraiment
ceux de l'empreinte de nos pas
parcs canada est bien conscient du
problème une nouvelle approche sur le
stationnement et les déplacements est
prévu d'ici deux ans le tout fait partie
de nouveaux plans pour la prochaine
décennie du parc maintenant nombre de
voix plus demandés base de stationnement
c'est pour la façon
le surintendant du cde lac louise doigt
une amie lui même sur place sinon il
aurait fallu prendre la navette parce
que le stationnement déborde dès l'aube
l'expérience des visiteurs devra
forcément être modifiées explique
françois mars non seulement certains
espaces de stationnement pourraient être
réduits des sentiers pourrait aussi
carrément devoir être fermé pour donner
un répit à la faune et à la flore d'un
site à l'autre le des types de visiteurs
différents deux des types de pressions
différentes donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on a par site on va avoir des plans
de gestion de l'achalandage qui vont ils
faire
bon c'est un immense parc mais aussi le
nom d'une municipalité de près de 9000
résidents transports en commun rue
principale piétonnière en été ou encore
stationnement incitatif la ville de
banff est également tout ce qu'elle peut
pour limiter l'empreinte des voitures
que ce soit par canada ou la ville tout
le monde à bord doit s'attaquer à la
réduction de l'empreinte écologique du
tourisme cpt aurait dit mano
protéger c'est exceptionnel sans
restreindre l'accès tout le défi est là
qu'on voit dans plusieurs autres c'est
du pac man 2 mondial à travers la
planète c'est la même chose banque n'est
pas unique donner accès aux gens au parc
c'est aussi réserver le parc en fiducie
pour toutes les générations
parce que pour conserver la carte
postale rocheuses l'envers du décor doit
changer ici mathieu cueilli radio canada
banff